give directly is the non-profit that
lets you send cash directly to the
world's poorest household which is more
cost effective than so many other types
of giving it's how you know you're
maximizing your donations help us reach
our goal of fifteen thousand dollars by
the end of the year go to give
directly.org Pacman
let's start today with the economy is a
massive recession coming is question one
question two is if so or if not what if
anything should you or I or anybody else
be doing about it we're seeing
increasingly hyperbolic predictions
about just a massive Global and American
recession coming is one coming I have no
idea I'll if you're waiting for me to
give my opinion I have absolutely no
idea whether a massive recession is
coming but really neither does anybody
else so let's talk through it and
explain first of all as a general
reality
humans aren't good at making economic
predictions just not good and secondly
when there are so many predictions
floating around someone is predicting
everything somebody is bound to be right
just by chance so you've got all the
people predicting a recession in a week
and then in a month and then in six
months and over the next 12 to 18 months
over the next two years or no recession
it's all going to be great somebody's
bound to get it right just by chance and
by the fact that we have 330 million
people in the United States many of whom
are making economic predictions that's
number two number three
predicting Doom and Gloom and recessions
generally gets more clicks and gets you
invited onto more television programs
and gets more articles written about
your predictions so it's important to
understand the bias to sensationalism
and zooming out and saying hey you know
what
I don't know what's going to happen over
the next two years but over the next 30
the market will probably return an
average of seven percent per year like
it always has that's not a particularly
titillating and exciting prediction and
that's not going to get you booked on
too many television programs so that's
another important thing to understand
the bias to sensationalism and a bias to
negative predictions and then number
four and this may be the most important
thing unless something changes with the
way our economy works there's always a
recession coming eventually so if you
predict a recession for long enough or
over a long enough period of time
at some point you're going to be right
because unless something changes and we
have no more recessions and again as
we've talked about before recessions are
sort of part of a capitalist economy if
you keep predicting recessions at some
point you're going to be right now let's
get into the specifics there are people
who have been predicting a recession a
massive recession since 2012 since 2014
since 2016. and the truth is that the
economy has been pretty good for most of
that time we had this covid collapse
which lasted like six weeks markets
collapsing unemployment rate increasing
and then it recovered relatively quickly
they've been wrong but if they keep
predicting it at some point they might
end up being right
so now let's get to a question about
numbers and data are there good or
accurate predictors of when a recession
is coming if we look back in history and
the answer is there are a handful of
indicators that do indeed seem to point
to the economy being quote good or quote
bad and these are terms that don't
really mean anything unless we decide to
Define them a little bit better so what
can we say about the indicators the
first thing is when you start seeing a
steady rise in job losses and a surge in
the unemployment rate that can be a good
indicator of a coming recession now we
don't have that at this point in time if
we look at job creation you see that it
actually looks pretty good you see if
you're looking at the screen here on the
left side of your screen is the
unemployment rate and on the right side
of the screen is job creation we had a
big spike in the unemployment rate
during the beginning of covid and we had
a big drop in
um uh payrolls at the at that exact same
time and then since then we've seen the
unemployment rate go down and remain
pretty low and we've seen uh payrolls
increase and remain uh quite frankly
quite high now is it possible is it
possible that you would see a recession
despite a solid employment situation
anything is possible but it's not the
way it tends to go historically
um I think I had one other chart here ah
yes so this is uh just all a little bit
of a more zoomed in look at the
unemployment rate and as you can see if
you go back a long way there's been sort
of like this range and we're well within
the range that we've seen for many many
decades at this point in time okay so
what other indicators could we look at
that might signal that a recession is
coming well another one is a decline in
GDP
and when you look at GDP you do see that
in that start of 2020 there's this
little Decline and it's a little
historically speaking but it was
significant at the time and you see that
um real GDP went down and then it has
gone relatively back to normal and
increased and there were a couple little
dips there but GDP really looks pretty
unremarkable so that's not an indicator
historically that a recession is coming
another indicator that historically has
been sometimes predictive of a recession
is retail sales and when you look at
retail sales and in fact we can look at
it um maybe over the 25-year period or
even a 10-year period you see that
retail sales are actually pretty okay
year over year there was this big
decline again that so much of this
mirroring what was going on with covet
very large decline in retail sales at
the beginning of 2020 March April and
then there was this very big income
increase looks like roughly when exactly
was that that was
um sort of like middle of 2021 and
retail sales are pretty unremarkable so
we're just not seeing the indicators
that are normally predictive of a
recession signal that a recession is
coming now what are the differences the
differences are
inflation
um although it is declining and I
believe will continue to decline has
been high historically high for about a
year or even a little bit more could
that alone even in the context of all of
these other indicators looking fine
could that maybe point to a recession
maybe but again it's if things are
changing if the circumstances that point
to a recession are different now than
they were in the past so we'll go we're
going to have to wait and see
now a really important thing to think
about at the individual level is what
should you be doing what should I be
doing what should individuals be doing
if we believe a recession is coming to
be best prepared they're really the
things that we should be doing all the
time so first and foremost do you have
an emergency fund when we think about an
emergency fund we're usually talking
about a thousand dollars so that if an
unexpected expense above and beyond your
normal monthly expenses comes up you
don't have to put it on a high interest
credit card or borrow money thousand
dollar emergency fund if you don't have
it in particular if you think a
recession is coming you should work to
establish that number two understand
your health insurance limits so that you
know if I have unexpected medical bills
and medical bills are often unexpected
what is the most that I might have to go
out of pocket so this means
understanding your deductible and
understanding your maximum out of pocket
number three paying down high interest
debt for two reasons number one paying
fifteen twenty percent interest on a
credit card is
um a very bad financially that's an
extraordinarily High interest rate and
if you can avoid paying that um you you
want to avoid paying that and number two
uh on the the high interest debt if you
believe a recession is or may be coming
and if you want to have as much
Financial flexibility as possible you
want to have credit available on those
credit cards and every dollar you can
pay off freeze up a dollar if indeed you
had no choice but to start charging
things in a future recession and then
number four
try to establish that four to six month
reserve of monthly expenses so in an
ideal world you would figure out what
are my monthly expenses you would
multiply by four or ideally six or if
you want to be you know have an extra
cushion and it's not possible for many
people by nine and have somewhere
between four and six or even nine months
of expenses in the bank so if your
income went to zero for that period of
time you would still be able to pay your
monthly expenses uh this is the type of
stuff we typically talk about on the
Pacman Finance channel so if any of this
is interesting we have this whole other
channel you can find it at youtube.com
pacmanfinance and if you go through uh
the topics we've covered you see that
most of the things I've mentioned are
listed as individual videos paying off
debt uh building a budget
um
etc etc so check that out at youtube.com
pacmanfinance if it is interesting to
you
Kerry Lake lost the 2022 Arizona
gubernatorial election she lost what I
mean by that is her opponent Katie Hobbs
got more votes and as a result Katie
Hobbs will be the governor I think
six-year-olds would understand this who
got more votes well Katie Hobbs got more
votes oh so who won Katie Hobbs one so
what does that mean it means Katie Hobbs
becomes the governor not Kerry Lake
because Kerry Lake lost because Kerry
Lake received fewer votes it sounds so
simple and yet Kerry Lake simply will
not go away Carrie Lake won't simply say
it's over uh Carey Lake delivering
another one of these highly filtered
I've never seen a blur filter the way
that Carrie Lakes videos have
she put out a video
updating her supporters about her fight
Now understand what it means that she is
fighting this
this small detail is so important
she's fighting for an election where she
lost
because her opponent received more votes
it's that simple and yet here she is
question is she grifting or is she
actually fighting I don't know let's see
if we can figure it out Arizona it's
Carrie Lake and I wanted to update you
on what's happening in our fight against
Arizona's sham elections and those who
run them for starters I want you to know
that I am firmly in this fight with you
Maricopa County just couldn't wait to
certify their botched election the
botched election where half of election
day voting centers were inoperable that
is a lie half of the voting senders were
not inoperable there were a few machines
that were malfunctioning for a portion
of election day we've talked about it
already
the botched election where election day
printers caused Mayhem across the county
the botched election where arizonans
were expected to wait in line two three
four even five hours simply to exercise
their sacred right to vote now remember
in other places other counties are
overwhelmingly Democratic areas making
people have to wait for hours to vote is
a strategy from the right they closed
down polling places and early voting in
overwhelmingly or places parts of the
states that favor Democrats in order to
create long voting lines which they say
is fine but here lines are indicative of
suppressing the Republican vote think
about that
arizonans were told to throw their vote
into a drawer where it might ultimately
end up in a plastic bin or a trash bag
Maricopa County where it took two weeks
to count is the poster child for broken
botched elections but if you bring up
any of these issues you are labeled an
election denier or well when you're
lying you are called a liar conspiracy
theorist they don't want us talking
about our shoddy elections under any
circumstances
they shut us down and made us fear
exercising our freedom of speech and
they canceled anyone who questioned past
elections
because of that many Americans did not
speak out and nothing was done to shore
up elections and now we are paying the
price again now remember nothing was
done to shore up elections in the
immediate aftermath of 2016 when real
vulnerabilities were identified
including the vulnerability of our our
elections broadly to foreign influence
many particularly Democrats tried to
actually do something about it
Republicans didn't want to hear it Mitch
McConnell didn't want to hear it so when
we identified a real problem we did try
to fix it they didn't want to fix it
because they like the results now that
they've identified imaginary problems
they say nobody else wants to fix it
because it's part of the way that the
left is stealing elections it is quite
literally backwards from reality
Arizona
America if we do not stand up and speak
up right now about the most dishonest
elections in the history of Arizona I
truly fear for our future our sacred
vote is supposed to be the great
equalizer of the people
and right now our vote has been trampled
upon we must work hard right now to save
it this is our last chance
those of you who are speaking out about
what happened on November 8th those who
testified before the corrupt Board of
Supervisors that includes the people who
said that there was treason the people
who said it was demonic that that's who
she's talking about we looked at clips
of that yesterday thank you and God
bless each of you the people she's
thanking many of them are insane I am
with you
here's what I'm busy working on I'm
working with a team a patriotic talented
lawyers on a legal case to challenge The
Botch elections now remember many of
those patriotic Talent talented lawyers
who got involved in 2020
many of them were disbarred
my team and I realized how important
this case is and what is at stake we
will file this case in accordance with
Arizona state law and you'll want to
stay tuned for this one trust me
so many have expressed concern about
Maricopa County's certification okay I
think you get it this reeks of
desperation and it reeks of grift Trump
fought in quotes fought which was really
fundraised money right the the last big
grift although maybe the last big grift
is is him now running for president
again Trump fought for two years and he
got nothing are they really going to
fall for this all over again so let's go
through the facts just so we're clear on
them Maricopa County officials said to
numerous media Outlets including to USA
Today no extra ballots were counted at
any voting sites in the county there has
been no evidence that people who wanted
to vote were unable to vote they've seen
no evidence that the ballot drop boxes
were insecure and they have also not
been contacted by many of the
individuals that Kerry Lake and others
claim are quote working on this issue
the county has processes to ensure legal
ballots are counted one time not zero
times and also not two times the the
drop boxes were secure
the tabulators which a few of them
briefly malfunctioned on Election Day uh
were repaired even the RNC which
initially filed a lawsuit over that
withdrew the lawsuit because it was
demonstrated to their satisfaction that
everything was on the up and up this is
all made up and at this point I
genuinely don't know is this number one
a way for Kerry Lake to keep raising
money I don't know the answer to that is
this number two Kerry Lake being a True
Believer in any of the nonsense that
she's saying including that she's
fighting for the election again the
election's over we're almost a month
beyond the election she lost her
opponent one or and I'm increasingly of
the mindset that this is the most likely
explanation or
is this Kerry Lake auditioning to be
Trump's VP is that really what this is
about that much like and I know I
mentioned this yesterday many Trump
supporters who maybe didn't literally
believe Trump won in 2020.
said it because it was how you pledged
allegiance to the team it's not the
pledge of allegiance to the flag it's
the pledge of allegiance to Trump and
the way you pledge allegiance is by
saying Trump won
is Carrie Lake doing the same thing and
wanting to position herself to be
Trump's 2024 VP by saying the exact same
stuff Trump said about 2020 and quite
frankly the exact same stuff Trump has
been saying about Carrie Lake's own
election which we will get to a little
bit later let me know what you think and
remember if you're watching our clips
and you are not yet subscribed on
YouTube please subscribe this is my Jeb
Bush please clap moment please subscribe
last month over 3 million people watched
our Clips but didn't subscribe we could
get to 2 million subscribers overnight
on YouTube if the people already
watching our Clips hit that subscribe
button help us out we're going to take a
quick break and be right back
I have done a ton of reading about how
to optimize charitable donations we all
have some limited amount we can give and
for me it's important to make sure I'm
giving in the most efficient way when
organizations give cash to families in
need about 90 cents on the dollar
actually goes to the recipient instead
of only about 50 cents of relative
impact with some of the more complex
programs like certain kinds of job
training for example that's why I
reached out to an amazing non-profit
called give directly about partnering
with us because give directly lets you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest households the David Pacman show
is trying to hit fifteen thousand
dollars in donations to give directly
before the year is up that's equal to
about a Year's worth of expenses and
Investments for 15 families in many
cases use the link below giving families
cash lets them choose for themselves
elves how to improve their lives they
buy food they repair their homes they
start a business they buy medication
they pay for their kids schools give
directly is doing truly incredible work
all around the world when you give to
them you're maximizing every hard-earned
dollar that you donate and they need
your help go to give
directly.org Pacman help us get to
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year the link is down below the
David packman show is a community funded
program we depend on your support we do
what we do every day including all three
YouTube channels the audio podcast the
radio show the TV show as well as now
the new white paper including the one
about building arguments without Burning
Bridges available for free at
davidpackman.com guide all of that is
funded by the membership program you can
sign up at joinpakman.com I believe the
normal prices are an incredible value
for the hours and hours and hours of
content we produce every month in
audiovisual and now written form but you
can also use a coupon code to save even
more that code is 24 starts now 24
starts now at joinpakman.com and of
course you get the award-winning bonus
show with your membership oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad now I admit all of the
Awards the bonus show has won our our
Awards we give out it's sort of like
when Trump wanted to give himself the
Congressional Medal of freedom but
nonetheless they are Awards and you can
sign up at joinpakman.com a New Zealand
prime minister Jacinda ardern did an
extraordinarily good job of pointing to
a reporter's very silly question and
saying would you be asking me that
question if I was a 60 year old man
instead of a younger woman this is super
interesting and we're going to look at
the clip New Zealand prime minister
Jacinda ardern was um doing a joint
press conference with the Finnish prime
minister Santa Marin both female leaders
younger than being in their 60s or 70s
as is common in many parts around the
world and the reporter asked why are you
meeting is it because you're both
younger women and Jacinda ardern among
pointing out many other problems with
the question said is that a question you
would ask about why other world leaders
meet let's take a look at this this was
very nicely handled yeah a lot of people
will be wondering are you two meeting a
lot by the way a lot of people will be
wondering is that actually true or is
this just a code for I want to ask this
question no matter what and so I'm
saying other people want to know who's
wondering about that here we go yeah a
lot of people will be wondering are you
two meeting just because you know you're
similar in age and you know got a lot of
you know Common stuff there you know
when you got into politics and stuff or
can kiwis actually expect to see more
deals between our two countries down the
line because there is something my first
question is I wonder whether or not
anyone ever asked Barack Obama or junkie
if they met because they were of similar
Age
We of course have a higher of men in
politics it's reality because two women
meet it's not simply because of the
agenda Finland exports into a New
Zealand 199 million dollars worth of
exports they have particular technology
in companies like Nokia biofuels even
basic industrial Wares that we use in
our buildings you won't be aware that a
large number of our elevators come out
of Finland agricultural Machinery New
Zealand on the other hand is trading
about 14 million dollars worth and it's
mostly in wine and beef there is huge
potential between us the EU FTA is a
launch pad for that but we need to make
sure that as Nations we don't just
simply go through the motions of a FTA
ratification but that is individual
Nations we look for the opportunities to
build on that economic agreement so for
me this is timely next year we're
looking to progress that FTA our meeting
today is a chance alongside the prime
minister's high level trade delegation
of significant industry leaders we
really leverage the economic
opportunities between our two countries
little would be known about the depth of
that relationship or the potential of it
but it's our job to further it
regardless of our gender
yeah we are meeting because we are prime
ministers of course but as Jacinda said
we have a I think you get the point this
is really a perfect example of the type
of question that she gets because of her
age and gender and I think it's really
important you know this is not a show
it's important to me that this is not a
show that uncritically repeats tropes
that are not actually true so when the
all you don't hear this too much anymore
but there was a while where it was 77
cents on the dollar women make 77 cents
on the dollar compared to men and if I'm
going to be using that I want to know
that that's actually accurate and so we
researched it we spent a while doing the
research we did a long form piece on it
and we found out that really we're
talking about 92 cents on the dollar
when we look at the gender pay Gap some
part of that Gap presumably due to
gender discrimination and part of it due
to other factors so that's the number I
use I want to have the actual data
this is just a perfect example of a
question that you're not going to get
you know when when Trump and who's a
70-something-year-old world world leader
I don't know I mean listen Putin's not
70 something I think he's close to 70.
but when Trump and Putin meet no one
thinks to say are you meeting because
you're both white men of a similar age
no nobody would ask that in any other
circumstance like this in fact when you
see someone like Trudeau and macron meet
younger men nobody's asking about
whether they're meeting because of their
age either so I think it's really
important that we not say that there are
isms when they aren't actually there
that were accurate with the claims that
we make Etc this is just straight up a
question that she's getting and that
they are getting both of the Finnish and
New Zealand prime minister they are
getting these questions because of their
age and gender plain and simple Georgia
is potentially going to to elect
Herschel Walker Herschel Walker doesn't
live in Georgia and it is now becoming
even more clear
because of an audio recording that has
been resurfaced so let me give you the
back story on this and then I'm going to
play a very important clip for you one
of the things we've known about Herschel
Walker a former football player running
as a republican for Senator in Georgia
against the incumbent Democratic senator
Raphael Warnock the runoff is on
December 6th then we will have live
results for you next Tuesday one of the
things that we learned about him is that
he really has lived in Texas for a while
but he claimed that he also lived in
Georgia and we are aware of a property
that Herschel Walker has in Georgia but
now due to a combination of new
reporting and a resurfaced audio tape we
have learned that he doesn't really live
in Georgia he admits that he lives in
Texas at least he did a few months ago
and also the property in Georgia was up
until recently rented out so he couldn't
possibly be living there yes he owned a
property
he had an address where he could say
this is my house but he didn't live
there and it was in fact rented out to
somebody else so let's go through this
piece by piece first and foremost we
have this new admission from Herschel
Walker the guardian is reporting about
it I live in Texas Herschel Walker's
speech adds to Georgia Senate Run
problems uh in a campaign speech earlier
this year Herschel Walker the Republican
candidate said I live in Texas I live in
Texas let's go to that audio
um it's not the best quality audio but I
think we're not going to have a problem
making it out anyone asked me
why did I decide to run for ascendancy
because to be honest with you this is
never something I ever ever told in my
life
and that's not the truth
but as I was sitting I in my home in
Texas so okay I was sitting in my home
in Texas that doesn't mean he doesn't
also live in Georgia okay but so that's
a start let's continue
and I was seeing what was going on in
this country
you know I live in Texas
yeah I went down to the board I live in
Texas and I went down to the Border this
is in the context of running for Georgia
Senate and he says I live in Texas and I
went down to the border now of course he
thought that it made sense strategically
to tout his Bona fides about knowing
what's happening at the border the
problem is you claim to live in Georgia
but you say actually I know about the
Border because I live in Texas and then
and it just keeps coming we learned
yesterday Herschel Walkers Georgia home
is a rental property the root reporting
via Yahoo news Herschel Walker's most
recent Scandal is actually an old one
going all the way back to his campaign
announcement last year it's been
reported that Walker actually didn't
live in Georgia the state he wants to
represent at least not full-time he owns
a house in Suburban Dallas that he and
his current wife occupied for years and
where Walker receives a homestead tax
exemption which is reserved uh oh for a
person's primary residence
but Walker has always had an Ace in the
Hole to use for plausible deniability he
still owns a house in Georgia a campaign
Finance report last year values the
house between 20 and 500 000 as long as
it exists Walker can rebut his critics
with the fact that plenty of people own
houses in more than one state now a new
report pokes holes in that idea with
receipts that until recently Walker's
Georgia home was occupied by renters who
paid Walker and his wife thousands and
The Daily Beast has the specifics
the house doubled as the Walker
campaign's official address when he
launched his bid records show it's owned
by Walker's wife solely who was
collecting rental income on it
it's his wife's house
and it at least was until recently
rented out Herschel Walker was clearly
not prepared to deal with this issue
in the way that Mehmet Oz was prepared
to deal with it Mehmet Oz certainly
isn't from Pennsylvania but he was
slightly more credibly able to make the
case that he's sort of from Pennsylvania
and lives in Pennsylvania he has more
than two houses I don't even remember
the number at this point in time so
Herschel Walker caught in another lie
now quite frankly I don't think this is
going to make a very big difference
um right-wingers will say Democrats are
the devil I don't care where Herschel
Walker lives it's better for the country
and for the state
for Walker to be representing us rather
than Warnock and he could live in Alaska
he could live in Timbuktu I don't really
care but the race is expected to be
relatively close there's a lot of little
things that have been going against
Herschel Walker and if this has even a
very small impact it's now a growing
list of things which hopefully will give
us the results that we want on Tuesday
we're going to be live with results on
Tuesday of course starting you know I
actually don't know I think the polls
close at 8 in Georgia I'm going to
double check that if indeed the polls
close at 8 we'll probably be live at 7
30 p.m eastern time and then the results
will start coming in if I learned that
the results won't even start coming in
until nine maybe we'll start at 8 30 but
I will be live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook I hope that you will join me
and we will have all of the clips I
played here today on our Instagram which
you can find by searching Instagram for
David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's talk a little bit about Republican
reactions to failed former president
Donald Trump having this white
supremacist dinner with Nick Fuentes and
Kanye West and others at Mar-A-Lago Mike
Pence does something which is it's
almost difficult to do in a sense Mike
Pence will come around
and make a statement supposedly based on
principle and whatever and it's like the
blandest most milk toast most
meaningless statement he could possibly
make that just Falls so embarrassingly
and humiliatingly short of what people
should be saying so as an example of the
type of reaction that I would like to
see more from Republicans just figure uh
just to find rather
the recent statement from Mitt Romney
which I don't have here available but is
widely available uh on just completely
unequivocal unquestioning condemnation
of this dinner that Donald Trump had
Mike Pence on the other hand
wants Donald Trump to apologize for the
dinner with the anti-semite a politician
I think he should apologize the
Associated Press has an article about it
we have the clip let's take a look at it
here is Mike Pence on news nation and
um he wants an apology and all the way
by the way notice there's a butt here as
well president Trump was wrong uh to
give a a white nationalist
an anti-semite and a holocaust denier a
seat at the table and I think he should
apologize for it uh wow he should really
apologize for that that was the wrong
thing to do you should denounce those
individuals uh and their hateful
rhetoric without qualification
with that being said as I point out in
the book with that being said you know
there's other stuff I need to mention
here because well I
I don't believe Donald Trump is an
anti-semite I don't believe he's a
racist or a bigot I would not have been
his vice president if he was that's a
lie now that that that's that's where it
starts to get unbelievable you wouldn't
have been his vice president come on
Mike we don't believe that you were
thirsty for power in the spotlight a guy
comes to you who's the nominee and he
says I want you to be my running mate
and you go uh I don't know I mean you're
you're kind of a little bit racist so I
can't I'm not going to do it nobody
believes that and uh you know people
often forget the the president's
daughter converted to Judaism yeah the
son-in-law is a devout Jew
um his grandchildren he's a Jew so
listen we've talked about this before
um it's less with Trump about I've also
made some of the same observations that
Mike Pence is making here uh Jared
Kushner his son-in-law is Jewish his own
daughter converted to Judaism his
grandkids some of his grandkids are now
Jewish with Trump it's not about the
type of anti-Semitism that would have
him denounce his own daughter it's about
similar to Trump with his preconceived
notions about people from certain
countries or same with Trump when it
comes to his views on lgbtq individuals
it's not the type of virulence
phobia or isms that some of my former
guests on the show have exhibited but it
is more of like a low-grade casual here
is my sort of beliefs about these people
and he tolerates them in whatever the
case may be but he's not so against the
racism and xenophobia and whatever that
he will unilaterally denounce it from
his movement and reject individuals who
do Harbor those views that's the type of
view and type of person that Donald
Trump is and and Views that he holds now
as far as Mike Pence here okay this is
both too little and too late when it
comes to Mike Pence and in fact it's
quite pathetic and what I mean for about
that is the following
if these
right-wing Republicans like Pence
wanted us to really believe
that they are completely against the
type of views espoused by Fuentes and
Kanye West and I don't even remember was
Milo yiannopoulos part of that dinner I
don't know I don't remember exactly who
was there
it would be more powerful
if they denounce the people within their
own parties that had these views because
there's members of the Republican Party
who are elected officials in the House
of Representatives and to some degree
even in the Senate who have a variety of
these views and there they are silent
and so it's easy to call out Nick
Fuentes or Kanye West and people who are
being not universally but but at least
by some political movements denounced
it's easy to do that call out the
elected officials in your party this is
too little too late for Mike Pence and
now I want to talk about Mitch McConnell
as well
Senate Republican minority leader Mitch
McConnell weighed in on Donald Trump's
Nazi dinner white supremacist dinner
call it whatever you want and he had
what sound like pretty strong things to
say about what Donald Trump did let's
take a listen to this first clip
there is no room in the Republican party
for anti-semitism
or white supremacy
that's a lie okay but let's continue
anyone meeting
with people advocating that point of
view
in my judgment
are highly unlikely to ever be elected
president of the United
so Mitch McConnell here is saying Trump
is essentially unelectable
because of that meeting that he had oh
wow well that's pretty strong words from
Mitch McConnell right well he also
during this same meeting this same press
avail
refused to answer
would you vote for Trump in 2020 would
you support Trump if he were to win the
Republican nomination I know you're
saying he is unlikely because nobody's
going to vote for a guy who has dinner
with these people but you know if they
did Mitch indulges if they did would you
vote for him for president
and Mitch McConnell refuses to rule it
out in light of what you said that
there's no room in your party for anyone
with Harper's event I submitic views if
Donald Trump wins the Republican
nomination would you support him look
let me just say again
there is simply no room
there's no room but I might vote for him
Republican party for anti-Semitism or
white supremacy and that would apply to
all of the leaders in the party who will
be seeking officers
did you see that
there is absolutely no room for this and
anyone who holds these types of meetings
in our party is not going to be able to
become president of the United States oh
okay would you vote for him for
president of the United States maybe
that's essentially what Mitch McConnell
is saying here so I'm going to say it
again
it's easy to denounce Nick Fuentes it's
easy to denounce Kanye it's harder
seemingly harder for them to denounce
the elements of the establishment who
play Coy with these same ideas and by
the way
um
McConnell's not the only one doing this
William Barr as an example Trump is a
threat to democracy and
would you vote for him in 2024 if he's
the nominee well I'm not going to vote
for a Democrat yeah I guess I would what
the threat to democracy you would vote
for it I mean Progressive Democrats
that's that's the most dangerous thing
that there is out there it's all the
same with these people so don't fall for
the mealy mouth oh it was wrong what
Donald Trump did he should apologize
says Mike Pence oh well where were you
when establishment members of your party
were doing all this stuff while you were
Vice President where were you that
Jewish space lasers and all this crazy
stuff silent they're pathetic it's easy
to denounce easy targets they should
actually look inward at their own
elected officials
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show something
strange is going on and it's strange
even for Donald Trump's standards he is
now regularly posting and reposting
messages to truth social in the middle
of the night truth essential forget
about the fact that he sometimes doesn't
even know what his own platform is
called forget about that for a second
um this really might be the end of trump
but I want to be very careful about
prematurely reporting the death of one
political career they can come back
there were people in 2016 who said Trump
has no chance and of course they were
wrong even recently even close to the
2016 election day I thought Trump had no
path to Victory so let's be careful
about declaring his political career
dead but Donald Trump does seem very
damaged at this point in time he's being
kept out of the Georgia a senate race
Herschel Walker's race in Georgia
and he is now regularly posting nonsense
to truth social all night long check out
this really strange stuff on Tuesday
around 10 30 a.m Donald Trump posted in
all caps remember you can never have
fair and free elections with mail-in
ballots never never never won't and
can't happen and then at 2 13 in the
morning early this morning Donald Trump
re-trothed it adding also in all caps
one more never
Trump also posting at 12 15 a.m this
morning this election cycle reminds me
so much of 2016. much more so than 2020
where I actually did much better got 12
million more votes Fox News and the Wall
Street Journal the wall Journal were
terrible to me to me much like today
until I won the election CNN when they
actually had great ratings was terrific
they covered me no matter where I went
24 7. the big difference is my record
best economy and Border no inflation or
Wars energy Independence record jobs
strong military worldwide respect and so
much more
and then dozens just dozens of other
retroths a retroth is sort of like a
retweet because truth Central just
copied Twitter but as you page down it's
just video posts and re-truths and just
endless endless endless posting dozens
and dozens and dozens of time uh he also
went after Karl Rove in one of his rants
posting quote Rhino Carl Rove a man with
a losing record the likes of which few
political operatives would be able to
get away with including his loss to me
in 2016. fight so hard and so stupidly
but is constantly on Fox News and the
once Great Wall Street Journal
explaining how things should be done and
he doesn't have a clue people can't
stand him a clone of even more unpopular
Paul Ryan who sadly runs Fox News Now on
a very bad path Rove is a denier of
deniers but it's completely misspelled
d-i-n-i-e-r am I missing something about
what Trump is doing here misspelled
denier of deniers which makes him a fool
watch so the important question
is whether Trump is actually weakened is
Trump actually weakened right now well
what do the betting markets say and what
do the latest polls say if we start with
the betting markets indeed Ron DeSantis
has as strong of a position in the 2024
Republican primary as he has ever had
Donald Trump is still in a very
respectable second place now the numbers
need a little bit of interpretation if
you had a situation here where Ron
DeSantis and Donald Trump had never been
president
and had either both or both or neither
had announced that they were running in
2024 and you saw these numbers you might
say okay I mean it's still very early
neither has announced and neither has
been president 40 32 okay it's kind of
not not hugely meaningful
the difference is Ron DeSantis in the
betting markets is now healthfully ahead
of Donald Trump Ron DeSantis hasn't
announced that he's running for anything
and Donald Trump has already been
president of the United States and yet
you see these numbers that is quite
interesting we then can look at actual
polling and we're only looking at this
like every couple weeks it's it's not
really a horse race yet but it is
interesting to see that the polling is
quite split right now a new yougov poll
has Trump up six over DeSantis but
notice it's only 36 to 30 and when you
look at more data you see that Don Jr is
pulling nine percent in that poll
imagine that Mike Pence is pulling eight
percent
Etc Trump plus six there's another poll
from communication Concepts which
already has DeSantis plus five 45 to 40.
and then as you read down the line you
see that there are polls in which Donald
Trump is leading and polls in which
Rhonda santis is leaving but importantly
it is so early in this thing and Trump
has already been president and Ron
DeSantis hasn't even announced that it
is quite stunning to a degree to see
Donald Trump polling this poorly Trump
was polling poorly at the beginning of
the 2016 Republican primary and so we're
making no conclusions but his
increasingly erratic Behavior being kept
out of Georgia when it comes to Herschel
Walker and both the polling and betting
Market data not looking particularly
good 2024 could be a very different
Republican primary and a contested
Republican primary against a former
Republican president that is a very
different situation and quite unique
we're going to follow it one of the best
things that could happen for the left is
for the right to do damage to Itself by
just getting involved in complete and
total nonsense when I hear complete in
total nonsense one of the first names
that comes to mind is Mike Lindell
pillow the CEO and founder of my pillow
who's been a guest on this program
multiple times don't miss my last
interview with him it was pretty whacked
Mike pillow is officially launching his
campaign for Republican party chairman
he is targeting Ronald McDaniel he says
Ronald McDaniel is leading the party in
the wrong direction and part of his
evidence of that is that the election
from a few weeks ago should have been a
massive Red Wave and it wasn't and here
is Mike pillow making it clear he's
really doing this take a listen it
should have been the biggest red wave in
the history of the world right ever it
should have been the biggest red wave in
the history of the United States
um and you know and it didn't happen and
why didn't it happen
um well the donors want to know we put
in all the money come on what what
happened well you better find out what
happened the the RNC completely lied to
the American people they enter their
donors and said that they would go after
election Integrity they called it
Integrity I call it election crime oh
yeah we're out for election Integrity
really what have you done what did you
do in 2020 You Know What You Did in 2020
but the RNC did everybody is they all
got together and here's a fact and said
oh we're not going to do anything
because we could get sued that would be
one of their excuses we could get sued
by the machine companies
well let's just let our country be
destroyed and let's just keep taking
money for our donors can can you imagine
if this guy was the chairman of the
Republican National Committee oh my
goodness and we hope that we can
override the algorithms
yeah we should we should encourage this
we should support this wholeheartedly
even if pillow doesn't win it would be a
very nice distraction for the Republican
party so maybe they don't do as many
damaging things and just on the off
chance that pillow wins it would wreak
total havoc on the 2024 primary it would
bring in a massively pro-trump RNC chair
which is the exact opposite of what the
establishment Republican party wants to
see at this point in time the left
should 100 percent be supporting this
and no I still haven't gotten those free
pillows from Mike pillow at this point I
don't even really know that I want them
so uh to to take kind of a more thirty
thousand foot View
of the RNC and the Republican Party
thinking about 2024. what the Republican
Party absent even the pillow stuff is
going to have to figure out for 2024.
is do they go fully against Trump
but if they do that the risk is Trump
wins the nomination and then what
happens or do they just remain sort of
neutral publicly behind the scenes try
to work against Trump so that if indeed
Trump is the 2024 Republican nominee
there's still some sort of plausible
deniability or ability to work with
Trump and to try to get them to do some
things that they would like to see him
do I quite frankly can't imagine what a
2024 Trump presidency would be or
starting in 2025 if Donald Trump were to
win because he seems completely
uninterested in actual governance that
there's not even a pretense of policy
other than these vague things well we're
going to shut down the border crossings
again even though nothing really changed
since he left and bite it's not really
policy he's not even pretending that
he's going to get us that beautiful
health care plan anymore so I don't know
what such a presidency looks like and
the RNC would probably be well advised
if they think there's any shot that
Trump has at this thing which clearly
Trump has some shot how do they stay
enough in his good graces that they can
actually get him to achieve some policy
things or or even pay attention to them
that's the real question I don't know
which direction they'll go in we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P here is a caller who is really
really really excited that Republicans
are taking control of the house in
January listen to this guy
Republicans now we control the house
now it's time for for payback so all
those low life Democrats
and then and smelly smelly Pelosi
the caller wants payback for those
Democrats and for smelly Pelosi I hate
to break it to this caller by the way he
doesn't actually sound that excited I
hate to break it to this caller but
Republicans have already made clear what
they are going to do in the two years
that they're about to control the house
number one they're going to obstruct
anything Democrats try to do to help the
country
they'll try to get in the way that's
number one and number two Republicans
will investigate Hunter Biden the
payback for all of the Terrible Things
Hunter Biden did to this country is
going to come
from investigations into Hunter Biden
which don't make any sense he's not
running for anything he's not in any way
involved in Joe Biden's presidency we
know what's coming it's going to be
pathetic it's going to be a joke on
today's bonus show the New York city
mayor
says that New York City is going to
treat the mentally ill
even if they refuse treatment or try to
refuse treatment what's going on here
we're going to talk about what's
happening in New York City Twitter is
reportedly now having trouble making
payroll
some employees are reportedly not being
paid on time at Twitter uh-oh what is
happening there and number three England
and Wales are now minority Christian
countries based on the latest census
what does the data mean what are the
majorities and what is the future of
England and Wales as what have
historically been Christian countries a
very interesting situation and is the
same coming to the United States the
demographics May well be pointing in
that very same direction all of those
stories we are going to be talking about
on today's bonus show which you can sign
up for at joinpakman.com also I want to
ensure
that everyone who wants it has
downloaded the free white paper on
consider getting people who disagree
with you politically to reconsider their
views it's called building arguments
without Burning Bridges you can get the
guide for free you know people write to
me and they say David I'm I have tears
in my eyes because I want the white
paper but I can't afford it the white
paper is free you also do not need to
email me for the white paper I had
people emailing me saying David can you
send me the white paper no it's all
completely automated and available to
you whenever you want it here are the
steps you go to davidpackman.com guide
you type in your email address and we
email you the white paper it's
completely free it's completely free
it's completely free over 1500 people
have now downloaded the white paper
unbelievable numbers get that get the
bonus show get the commercial free audio
and video streams of the show do the
entire thing and I will see you on the
bonus show in mere moments
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors give directly is
the non-profit that lets you send cash
directly to the world's poorest
household which is more cost effective
than so many other types of giving it's
how you know you're maximizing your
donations help us reach our goal of
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year go to give
directly.org Pacman